what's up pelina please go like the
video if you indeed like this video
um anthony's voice sounds like miley
cyrus do you want to drink some water
no get some water now let's go what's up
all right
i always wanted to do that and actually
mean it
all right
so um the federal reserve uh jerome
powell
said that basically he's um
giving up on a soft landing what do we
think
i mean
there's two ways to look at this one
thank you for being honest thank you for
trying to be rational i think that he is
uh becoming more and more transparent
with his viewpoints he's becoming less
of i have to repeat the talking points
and he's becoming more hey this is where
i think we are uh which is appreciated
at the same time there's a lot of folks
who say you get no credit for now saying
this stuff like you should have known
this before uh and we shouldn't be in
this situation both sides have a strong
argument uh i think it will be very
difficult for them to deal with the
confluence of events of 8.6 inflation
hiking interest rates
going into a potential recession where
contracted gdp in q1
uh that is just an environment that i
don't see us uh coming to a uh
a soft landing in any way and so they're
going to be forced to make a decision
will they stay committed to raising
interest rates or
will they actually go ahead and end up
uh
reversing course i think that they will
have to reverse course at some point
yeah i think i appreciate the honesty to
be honest
the honesty to be honest
he said that we think there are pathways
for us to achieve the path
he he's talk he talks like me we think
there are pathways for us to achieve the
path back to two percent inflation while
still retaining a strong labor market we
believe we can do that that's the one
you took away because the tweet that i
saw that was all time was he said we
understand better how little we
understand inflation yeah he likes
repeating let's run that one back real
quick for the ladies and gentlemen at
home we understand better
how little we understand inflation which
by the way yeah true yes that that is
true the way it's said though is a
little uh kind of uh confusing or
repetitive uh but yeah this stuff is
hard like i also this is very important
it is so easy to sit here and rail on
the central bankers uh on the economist
etc it's nearly an impossible job
predicting an economy and all of the
various inputs into it and then what
those outputs will be is literally
impossible there's no one who gets it
right 100 of the time
as we previously talked peter lynch
famous investor who used to manage the
fidelity magellan fund has this joke
that he always says if you spend 16
minutes
on macro predictions and macro economy
analysis you spent 14 minutes too long
it's because nobody knows what's going
to happen in the future and so what we
are asking is a central banker to sit
and look at a set of data which is
backwards looking the inflation data
they're using to make decisions today is
based on the readings from a month ago
so it's backwards looking data but make
decisions today on what's going to
happen in the future
that is just by definition nearly
impossible to do and then oh by the way
it's not just one number or one decision
it's across the entire economic system
this is very difficult i think that
human-led monetary policy uh is exposing
itself for its vulnerabilities its
complexities and its challenges right
now
all right what's going on mortgages
thank you for the analysis miley um
after
i just wanted to say that
after rising steadily for three weeks
some more you try to be careful
that's exactly what she sounds like it's
like if you got financial you know
analysis from miley cyrus after rising
steadily for three weeks mortgage rates
dipped slightly last week prompting a
small increase in refinance activity
activity from home buyers however pulled
back further leaving total mortgage
demand basically flat from the previous
week what do we want to talk here about
the psychology of homebuyers so this is
all psychology which
most people look at it and they think
that uh there's this like super
sensitive response to changes in
interest rates so if interest rates go
up a little bit they're like oh demand
might cool down if interest rates come
down a little bit demand will uh
increase
and that is true
in kind of uh uh medium to long term
but it's not true week to week and what
do i mean by that is
there's not enough time for the market
to internalize any sort of change in a
week-to-week basis
and there's a macro psychology at play
so if you're somebody
and you are in q1 going into q2 of this
year
you've pretty much made a decision
interest rates direction are going up or
they're going down obviously they're
going up so what do you do i'm not going
to be in the market
you don't care about the week-to-week
changes in the interest rate all you've
done is you've psychologically
put yourself in a position where you've
said we are potentially headed towards a
recession i am going to pull back and
you start to do that across all spending
but also hey i'm not going to go buy a
house i'm not going to go i try to
refinance i'm not going to go spend more
money on you know frivolous things and
so once that occurs there may be week to
week even month-to-month fluctuations of
the mortgage rates but the difference
between five and five and a half percent
as an example doesn't matter like people
psychologically have already pulled back
from the market and that ends up being
uh the the prevalent or kind of
dominating uh driver of activity
okay
all right what's up next with stimulus
so more than half of california's
residents may soon receive a stimulus
check from the state
as part of an inflation relief package
worth 17 million an estimated 23 million
eligible californians californians will
receive payments totaling up to a
thousand fifty dollars for joint filers
with at least one dependent later this
fall newsome is calling this a middle
class
rebate he's saying that's more money in
your pocket to help you fill your gas
tank and put food on the table what do
you think
i may not
i can't even with newsome
you can't even i cannot even with him
i think that there's uh two arguments
that uh are likely to be made here
ready yeah first one
are they trying to buy votes
oh interesting wait why because he's
doing it well because
for example if for example uh a
politician said hey i'm gonna run for
office and they went and they said
polina if you vote for me i'm gonna give
you a hundred dollars
hold on i'm gonna give you a hundred
dollars they stood outside the polling
center and they said go inside and vote
that would be illegal right and people
would uh say that that's unethical
if
a major driver of them doing this is
that we are heading into midterm
elections and they simply want to give
free money because then those people be
like oh i just got the check right it's
the same thing if both sides of the
aisle do this the this was an allegation
levied against trump with the trump
bucks it's now an allegation being
levied against newsome so two different
sides of the aisle they both are uh
doing similar things
but
it is part of the conversation is if
there was not midterm elections this
year would they do this i think there's
a strong argument that they would not
what i have a question i don't
understand how this works but
has this happened before on the state
level it's always been like federal
right there's all kinds of nuances
around rebates and there's always
programs it's never been explicit from
to my knowledge like this where they're
calling it an inflation relief package
but here's the other thing so it can
happen on the state level i'm just
surprised more state legislators haven't
done that because they're because the
other state legislators aren't [ __ ]
idiots
to be completely honest like this is by
the way just to make this clear this is
the dumbest thing in the world do you
want okay guess what they're paying the
people joint filers that make between
250 000 and 500 000 so families
families that make between a quarter of
a million dollars and half a million
dollars a year they're giving them 400
why are they doing that because it is
[ __ ] stupid
but that's why they're doing it this is
the dumbest thing in the world
because guess what this does not solve
your problem this doesn't solve the
problem they're trying to solve i don't
think that's the problem that's why this
is dumb is because what they are doing
is yes giving someone whether it's 200
or a thousand dollars it is helpful in
the short term but that's exactly what
they did in 2020 is they gave people a
check now they said we want to help this
short-term mitigation of pain but the
problem was they created a long-term
problem and loose monetary and fiscal
policy drove 40-year high inflation all
california is doing here is they're
saying we will give you a check well
what do you think 9.5 billion dollars is
going to do it's not going to provide
relief from inflation in terms of
bringing inflation down it's going to
further drive the inflationary pressures
my question is if you're going to do
this why not go big like
three don't give them ideas no
give them a million dollars
no well first of all california don't
have a million dollars to give to every
citizen unless you do bad math on
twitter uh but i think that there is uh
a very strong argument that what we are
watching is politicians are exposing
themselves for not understanding
anything about economics if you think
handing somebody who makes a quarter of
a million to half a million dollars a
year four hundred dollars is going to be
inflation relief
you literally are unfit for office like
that's insane but do you think they did
that because they couldn't just exclude
those people
i guess they could have well what about
the guy who makes five hundred and five
hundred thousand and five dollars
why'd you leave him out what about the
woman who makes a million dollars a year
why'd you leave her out
yeah i don't know
right so again it goes back to this idea
that uh many states are likely to pursue
this
but what they are doing is it sounds
good it's theoretical let's give them
money so they can put literally they
said put gas in their cars and food on
the table
unfortunately what they are doing though
is they're addressing a short-term
problem at the expense of the long-term
pain and it's probably going to get
worse
all right anybody has questions about
this talk to my dad who
lived through two hyperinflations
like you know you get this this coupon
for like bread and this coupon is that's
what they're talking about they're
talking about a gas tax holiday they're
talking about we're gonna give you a
check so you can go buy food
in the united states of america the
greatest country in the world the
country that billions of people around
the world look at and say over the last
couple of decades i want to get there
because that's where the american dream
is that's where capitalism is and that's
where if i get there
i got a shot to build a life of
happiness and financial security
that was the promise of the american
dream but to play devil's advocate
people are struggling so that there is a
relief for those people of course but
you can't claim it's like showing up
there's a there's this uh uh um
well-known uh kind of uh uh what they
call it um like story or or uh
comparison
is
central bankers set a building on fire
and then they show up and like hey we're
the firemen and they want credit for
like trying to put the fire out but like
you started the fire so are you an
arsonist or are you a fireman right like
is this a classic example
what they're doing now is exactly the
same at from politicians
they're showing up and they're trying to
claim that they're firemen oh we're
gonna help with inflation we're gonna
help with inflation but actually what
they're doing is they're literally
saying let's help put the fire out by
throwing more matches into the fire like
it's stupid
and so again i understand i understand
that people are saying yes a 300 check a
400 or 500 thousand dollars that can
help in the short term but what we have
to ask ourselves are we more concerned
with trying to help somebody bridge the
next 30 days or are we actually trying
to solve the problem because if you
think about it the united states
government gave people 1200 checks and
in turn they got 40-year high inflation
was it worth it
there's a debate i don't have the
answers i don't know what the answer is
but there is a very strong debate
as to whether the stimulus checks were
worth what ended up being the longer
term problem gotta go think on that all
right what's going on with michael
micro strategy said it purchased 480
bitcoin for about 10 million dollars an
average price of twenty thousand eight
hundred and seventeen dollars per coin
look
what do you think me yeah you i think
how i mean is michael saylor just gonna
keep buying bitcoin
he's got so much
well the company has now just under 130
000 well he's got a lot personally as
well from what he said uh they spent 10
million dollars about 480 uh purchase
price around 20
800
they've got just under 130 000 bitcoin
and the average price is you know 30 000
the key to uh this entire strategy which
he's outlaid is he has two strategies at
his company they have a business
intelligence strategy they're gonna go
they're gonna sell software they're
gonna drive revenue uh and try to
continue to uh to reap profits and then
at the same time they have a treasury
strategy which they're going to continue
to convert their dollars into bitcoin
he's just continuing to do the strategy
and i think what uh more so than
anything it's not that he spent 10
million on bitcoin it's that it's very
clear don't listen to what he's saying
watch what that company is doing they
continue to buy regardless of it the
price is high or low and they're just
essentially dollar cost averaging into
the asset and whether you think that's a
good strategy or not you got to tip your
cap and you gotta say to yourself hey
these people have a strategy they are uh
committed to it they're showing
conviction and they're continuing to
execute the strategy let's see what
happens
okay all right what's up with mark we
had moon dust yesterday now we got mars
because all these depressing topics i
needed something all right so nasa
is asking the people like you and me
to go and help them uh identify martian
clouds using the citizen science
citizen science platform zuniverse and
the information may help researchers
figure out why the planet's atmosphere
is just one percent as dan as dense as
earth's even though ample evidence
suggests the planet used to have a much
thicker atmosphere so i literally i
spent all morning identifying can you
find this stuff it's on nasa
so so then it serves you up like
pictures of clouds and you have to
identify them and the whole point is
that you know like you still need humans
even though ai is like so sophisticated
but i'm
so they so they are asking the average
citizen to conduct uh labeling of photos
yes and then you can talk to other
citizens that are also labeling clouds
i'm sure those are riveting
conversations amazing morning today but
how cool and they also have like other
um things that you can do it's all about
like citizens
identifying things
why you like this
why i like this no it's so interesting i
was sold on uh this whole idea of uh
getting people to label
the photos until you said that uh it was
an amazing morning because of the
conversations with other people well no
i wasn't talking i was just observing oh
what were they saying i don't know
they're talking about the clouds
but but did you know that there's
different types of clouds
uh tell me more yeah there's clear sky
there's well if there's no clouds is
that is that a type of cloud or is that
just absolutely there's like those like
weird clouds that are kind of like yeah
i'll show you later but it's just really
cool because if you have some time on
your hands you could go help identify
clouds on mars how do they know that the
people who are doing the identification
of the clouds actually know what a cloud
is and can identify they tell you they
show you pictures oh they train you and
then they unleash you yes
okay
it's really cool okay all right
people are saying that i'm a hater
because i'm not into the mars cloud alex
k said thank you paulina for injecting
some fun into this segment
that's my burner
who who's that no my burner on youtube
is alex k why
because i said that no you did not
all right thank you very much
i appreciate it uh hey you did you like
this video great we make five of them a
day and post them here on this channel
make sure you subscribe like the video
and see you next time